you've been able to travel there's a lot  of things that your family like has been  able to provide 70k like it's hard to  send your kids even on an AAU team yeah  okay so the question is uh because are  you getting that number because there's  a there's a a study out there that says  seventy thousand dollars is the Baseline  that creates happiness and anything  above that is more materialism and  consumerism is that where you're getting  that number I got the number because  it's a little more than what I used to  make at my sales job okay so it's just  like that's what I used to make like  roughly 50k okay so you said ideally  like honestly I when I was just thinking  the same job that I used to have